this is the future of our society they
win in demographics they already have
almost the majority now when it comes to
youngsters and and we are they are
representing as well an enormous
electoral Force why are they pampered by
in my country by the social Democrats
they are pampered because they represent
not they represent an enormous voting
force not only because the leftish and
the liberal in invented the concept of
the Multicultural Society and the
cultural res relativism in the 60s and
70s and they are not willing to admit
that they make make a mistake sometimes
politicians are almost like humans not
willing to admit a mistake but they have
they have a big interest in it they are
those voots we have had municipality
elections in rdam where the former party
of Mr F time was very strong where they
lost the elections because of the Muslim
vote no it's already happening today it
is it is it is there
in the United States we have one Muslim
Congressman out of
435 and his election was hailed as a
Triumph of multiculturalism and
diversity and even though he uh uh well
there many questionable things about him
uh I was wondering are there similar
figures in National governments yeah in
the uh in Europe already Yes we well in
in my country in the Netherlands and I
make I made a bit of bit a big noise
about that and I had a debate and I had
a motion of non-confidence which
unfortunately was rejected we have uh
two Muslim um members of cabinet and I
did not complain because they were
Muslim because this would be ridiculous
yeah but uh one person from turkey and
one from what is the problem that they
have double nationality a lady secretary
uh who of Justice who is besides Dutch
also Turkish and a minister of social F
who is um also Moroccan for Moroccan
nationality and I think this is
something we should and we can never
never expect because if you have double
nationality you have not only double
loyalties but there is also for instance
the Turkish Constitution um gives you
certain duties uh and gives you certain
penalties for instance if you are
critical to the Assyrian problem or to
uh to the problem of of Cypress uh
according to the penal law in Turkey if
you are Turkish person living abroad um
um you get 50% more uh of of a penalty
or you have to be able to go to the Army
imagine if we are and I wish I hope we
will never will we be in a war with
Morocco what would this member of the
Dutch cabinet do I mean where is the
Loyalty besides the Loyalty by the
Moroccan Constitution so it's happening
already today and I think it's it's it's
very wrong you should have only one
loyalty and I would have said by the way
the same if there was a minister who had
also the passport from Sweden because
the principle is the same but it's not
from Sweden it's from two um Arab
countries and the influential and the
double the double um loyalties are
increasing and increasing people don't
like it I got a lot of support when I
initiated that debate insh Parliament
but of course it was rejected by 90% of
the of the par probably because they saw
it as racist they did they surely did
yes and yet race has nothing to do with
this no like I said I also said in
Parliament that if the the the lady who
by the way is is a very good politician
I have nothing against her it's about
double loyalties if she would have been
Swedish with blond hair I would have
made exactly the same point and people
said I don't believe that you only say
it because she's she's she's from
Turkish um origin which is
nonsense one last question and I thank
you for your time to us this morning uh
if you became prime minister of the
Netherlands uh what would you do besides
limiting immigration which of course is
very important to try to stem the tide
of
islamization well besides exactly what
you said the stop of the immigration uh
I would first because I believe that
it's also a problem of way of thinking
like I said I would U try to stop the
fact that we are cultural relativist I
would what what the Germans call a light
culture in my country that word has a
very negative connotation because it's
in German but what it means is a leading
culture not a monoculture of course
other cultures are welcome but I would
put in our constitution an article that
our dominant culture is based on
humanism and the judeo Christian values
this is very important it's more than
symbolism because you can make a lot of
laws referring to that article and
secondly I would want to stop the
Islamic
symbolism I don't like that there are
almost more Ms than churches in the
Netherlands so I would I would want to
stop not only the the foreign funding
from Gulf countri in s area to buy M but
there are enough MK in the Netherlands
today I would want to close Islamic
schools not because it's like again on
out of racist motives because I believe
that Islam like I said not the people
but the ideology is very dangerous and
the worst thing we can do is if you want
people that are already in our countries
to assimilate and I do that um um well
young children and young boys are being
brought up and being educated with an
ideology full of hate so stop the is
stop it we could have programs like we
even have today in the Netherlands for
voluntary remigration to the country of
origin a lot of people use it but it
could be done uh far more than it done
today and I think that it's very
important because nowadays in the
Netherlands we have almost every month
debates when there is a lot of crime
committed by Moroccan youngsters or
people from Islamic or origin and that
is not they don't commit a crime with
the Quran on their hand but it has a
very big cultural component and um um
people are not only fed up with that but
this is really not an incident but a
structural security problem in the
Netherlands and it shows the difference
of values I mean I'm calling people
women just because they are walking
through the streets a horn or stabbing
ambulance uh Personnel or the police or
whatsoever no resp for anything else I
mean people from 13 years old say on the
street to Dutchman and wait in 10 years
we will be the boss here and we will
kick your queen out as the first I mean
this is not one person who says it it's
the general attitude and I believe that
we would be far more straight we used in
the Netherlands unfortunately we are a
country of consensus and we have a
multi-party system we only compromise we
like to hold each other hands and sing
Christmas songs under the Christmas tree
all year long nothing nothing really is
changing and what I wish is that that we
give an example that we tell them that
if you are not complying to our values
and our laws then there is no place for
you in the Netherlands if you adhere and
assimilate to our laws okay you can stay
you are equal as anybody else but
unfortunately you are not and if you are
not we'll strip you of your nationality
if you have a double nationality and we
sent you away to Morocco Robert I always
sent in My Parliament uh to the speaker
and to our prime minister that if you
would do that I am sure that we would
only need one or two planes because
people would see that we would take this
problem seriously and they would change
their tune if you stab somebody now or
or or beat up a guy or woman as a
Moroccan you will get um um Community
work for 2 hours or for 10 hours or
something like that there is no penalty
and and and and and the government even
gives incentives to that so be stronger
be tougher show them that there is never
a place for violence
Islamic violence in the Netherlands like
I said the most important thing is
immigration a stoping immigration and
it's very important if you L as a few
last words that I'm not talking about
Asylum Seekers I'm talking about
immigration I voted in My Parliament in
favor of for instance um um homosexuals
for from Iran to get temporary visas as
Asylum seekers in the Netherlands this
is something different that should
always be a place for people like that
in the Western countries I'm talking
about what I say um um the the the
Islamic um in that is coming from a lot
of M from a lot of Islamic countries I'm
talking about the colonizing of our
country by huge amounts of Muslims that
are really not willing to integrate but
willing and whose own and sole aim is
that at the end of the day to overrule
and to submit and to use every possible
means to achieve that we should be we
should stand up and tell them will never
happen and not is enough we will defend
our own culture and Heritage Bravo yes
well I hope that you will one day be the
Prime Minister and who knows and you're
great in any case you're a great hero in
Europe and around the world thank you
very much and an example that I hope
many more politicians will follow I hope
so so uh here Wilders thank you very
much for uh and it's a pleasure to be
your guest and uh I read really I'm not
just saying that to be kind but um your
books are being read so much in Europe
and you really seen as an icon in our
fight and you asked you asked before
what could American and and people do in
order to help and well maybe you allow
me to say one thing please you will make
an enormous contribution and help by
staying and contining writing all those
fabulous books thank you very much
certainly will thank you thank you bless